if someone asked you to think of a
magnificent hunter chances are a Lions
image would pop into your head they have
virtually no predators the earth is
their buffet table well with at least
one exception this African crested
porcupine is surrounded by young lion
cubs the adults are too smart to fool
around with this small Beast those
quills may be modified hairs but they
are needle-sharp strong and there are
plenty of them what the adults know is
that porcupine needles can actually
pierce the flesh of life and these
wounds could even kill it nevertheless a
porcupine is a juicy delicacy and these
curious Cubs look for a way to get a paw
under it flipping an attack but the
prickly porcupine fends off the Cubs and
eventually good sense wins out over
hunger the victorious porcupine moves
off yeah
king of the jungle big deal
this porcupine has to walk through a
pride of adult lions they're interested
but once again those quills give the
porcupine the equivalent of an
impenetrable missile defense shield ahem
and this pride of lions doesn't have
much to be proud about today